5 26 on your monday morning hey there's  a sign of progress at one of ndot's many  ongoing projects  yes work is grinding along in the big  squeeze on the 95 515 between the  spaghetti and eastern in the centennial  bowl in the far northwest valley where  the 95 meets the northern 215 beltway  but today we're heading to the far  northeast valley where the northern  beltway meets i-15 this is endos i-15  north corridor project we like to call  it the speedway bull well the first of  what will be several flyover ramps  opened up last week making a direct  connection between the south 15  and westbound 215 replacing a clunky  arrangement of stop signs and feelings  like maybe you were in no man's land  well there's still a lot more work to be  done on all of these projects however  seeing progress is encouraging buckle up  drive carefully please put down that  phone something driving you crazy email  me traffic eight eight news now dot com